members of The White House staff
protested against their own president uh
we are Congressional staffers on Capitol
Hill also also these people did and we
are no longer comfortable staying silent
and I want to connect this to something
else that happened on real time because
one of the things we started talking
about uh later in the show was how there
are a bunch of uh staffers at the White
House who are not happy with Joe Biden's
policy as it pertains to Israel and Gaza
and they're protesting uh and uh well
take a look a couple of weeks ago
members of The White House staff
protested against their own president uh
we are Congressional staffers on Capitol
Hill also also these people did and we
are no longer comfortable staying silent
well you're staffers you're supposed to
say silent what are you talking about
yeah you my boss is doing a job and I
thought I'd go public with it I mean
this is hundreds of people in Biden's
staff and on on uh Cong Democrat
Congressional Democrat staff who are
publicly going against them because
they're not supporting Hamas enough you
fire them period you fire all of them
that's it it's not it's not up for
debate if you had if you had five
staffers standing outside saying Bill
Mah's the devil what are you going to do
you're going to fire them right of
course you're going to fire them it's as
simple as that you fire these people but
the inmates are running the
Asylum yes you fire these if I could
agree with that guy we got to play more
clips of that guy he's good yes you fire
them it it but you see how this is
connected to what I was just talking
about and what Tucker was talking about
in a city where nothing works we don't
have rules anymore right you jump the
turns how you break the laws we'll
selectively decide who we're going to
prosecute and everything else and then
at the federal government level these
these staffers they're there they're
hired to do the job of the
administration you vote for the
president you vote for Congress and the
and the Senate right your
representatives and the Senators if the
staffers don't like what they're doing
you fire them that's it but but we are
watching
the collapse of all of our systems and
the real question is not what happens
during the collapse we're in the midst
of the collapse right now the question
is what happens after the collapse and
as Tucker is pointing out that's when
the fascists show up that's when Gavin
Newsome shows up and he uses the power
of the corporations with the power of
the government to to put in the most
authoritarian say 15minute cities
whatever it might be say a social credit
system because people will beg for the
control at that point will be like oh my
God everywhere I go uh there's a chance
of being raped or murdered I guess I
will take all of that authoritarian
control